Reflect briefly on the varying friendships,
relationships, and social groups that you
are a part of.
Consider how different they are, person-to-person,
group-to-group, and how your own personality
often changes depending on whom you are with.
This is because humans are socially echoic.
We conform our behavior to echo the behavior
of those around us.
Each social encounter we engage in carries
with it its own unique character; a weighted
average of all the personalities involved.
We are merely actors, constantly playing different
roles to suit the different scenes we enter
in life.
Our ability to adapt to and reflect these
shared scenes and personalities is what allows
us to experience successful friendships and
relationships.
What we must careful of, though, is what scenes
we choose to enter.
We must be selective with who we surround
ourselves with.
We must be aware of how like-minded and mutually
valuable our friends and partners are to us.
If not, we risk losing sight of our core self
and what we stand for.
We risk reducing our intellect and values.
The saying that a team is only as a strong
as their weakest link is very much applicable
to the science of human sociality.
Therefore, we should strive to have a balance
of relationships that challenge and support
us.
Like childhood bullies suffering from insecurity,
people love to bring the world down to their
level so they don’t feel quite so alone.
Don’t let these people infect you.
You have the privileged ability to choose
who you spend time with in life.
Choose wisely.